you're operating I feel like within
you're operating at the top of your
bubble and then by Bubble I mean there's
a specific Lane on YouTube which you
really tap into and there's also another
Lane which is like Florida I feel like
in Florida you're like Rogan like when I
was walking around after doing your pod
everybody's I just saw you on pbd and
that was the same thing after I did
Rogan like the first time just walking
around people like oh should I just saw
your Rogue and et cetera and but I feel
like happens is every time you bubble
out of that right
you're gonna get the scrutiny of the
casuals right the people who don't
really know you don't know your
experience don't know your story they
start hearing about you and they're
going to have resentment or animosity
for your opinions that are different and
then they start attacking you for the
things you said and you said
some people would go very wild things
some people would also say that's very
rational your take right depending on
your like politics but I feel like when
you offered Tucker the 100 million right
that was outside of bubble did you feel
some heat after that oh absolutely Big
Time absolutely what did people say
listen you want to dance I love it
I love it oh my God I can't even
describe it to you like I get excited
when I even think about what that's
going to look like you know look for me
uh everybody fights in a different way
okay there's different styles to
fighting uh you know when when you have
a fighting style where you know Larry
Holmes Versus Ali versus you know you
know all the Ken Norton versus you know
four men versus you can go and look at
everybody so it's a different style on
how they would fight right I think in
this world of communication there's a
different way to fight and deliver your
message to yet stand your ground but at
the same time maintain a relationship
with the other individual that is an art
it's not easy to do it's very hard and
the way you do it is by I think what is
unattractive is the final one is when
you're 100 percent I'm right you're
wrong you're an idiot you're a and
some people do it that way I don't think
you're opening up the door to want to
have that exchange I think if there's an
opportunity to say listen man find some
leaks of my argument what do you think I
love that you do that yeah tell me it's
a cool thing maybe I'm off yeah I'm okay
with that if I can compliment you a bit
more not only do you bring on people
that we're going to disagree with you
you don't bring on like punching bags
from the other side that you could just
bully in an argument you bring on smart
people who make great cases and I think
that's really cool and rare in this
space
and going off what uh Andrew said about
you get hate from the general audience
that doesn't necessarily know you how
would you describe yourself
to them or to to who to to them everyone
in general well I mean I think it has to
do with how how long like for example
I'm asking him about the story okay the
the the unique story of this building
next door right Mom how he grew up down
the street how far the bike they don't
want him to ride the bike because he
goes the other way October 30th birthday
40 family yesterday's exchange and text
I'm curious about this guy's a product
right I'm curious about him as a human
being but he didn't become who he is
today because of what I've consumed of
him the last five years I want to know
what prompted this guy to be here
unfortunately in America too many times
our judgment is on who this person is
Chelsea Handler makes this video perfect
example Chelsea Handler makes this video
calling out Adam one of our guys and he
she says whoa look at this guy Alpha
trust me you are definitely not an alpha
he gives me the sde energy and trust me
I can tell you for a fact this guy on
Alpha motivation zero you're not Alpha
this is coming from an alpha you're a
zero is what you are so she calls him
out and she talks about the fact that
it's it's incredible to be childless
it's phenomenal to wake up and not have
any kids have sex with anybody want
drink as much alcohol all this she
says video goes viral 50 million views
on Twitter right whatever the number is
okay so the average girl is gonna watch
that and say what that's right screw
that sde I also want to drink and be
able to be with any man I don't want to
have any kids does anybody even want to
have this kind of responsibility in life
I want to be free because we're equal as
men screw them I don't need them great
then you go read her Memoir where she
tells a story about when she was nine
years old
at the age of nine her brother she
describes who was 22 I think they have
six kids total Mom and Dad I think one
was a car salesman it was a good family
six kids
the older brother 22 she calls him my
second father my first boyfriend I was
in love with him in a way of loving my
older brother but he was my world he's
going on a Mountain hiking uh trip his
last words to her was can I wait to see
when I get back the guy dies
climbing a mountain while she's nine
years old
he never comes back
then when he dies
she says my mom and dad lost it the man
I needed next was my dad my dad I didn't
have my dad anymore because he lost his
mind I don't blame him he says in that
moment I realize the pain of losing
someone I love and secondly I saw my dad
the pain he went through of losing his
child
of course I want to have a hard time
with commitment I want to type kids and
get married do you blame her when you
read the story then you're like okay
Chelsea I understand it's easy to troll
her and it's easy for her to troll other
men but we don't know that story so if
somebody from the outside says who's
Patrick David here's a rich guy he's
probably raised in a you know I remember
there was a time in the third year the
insurance company I was paying comp more
than my competitors were a rumor started
circulating saying pass link to oil
money and you know what I do with that
rumor I ran with it I said you're right
I have oil money I can pay to count them
on your campaign I don't have oil money
man I work out a 99 cent store in
Inglewood by Great Western Forum 15
years but I love that rumor so I ran
with it so if somebody doesn't know your
story great you can say what you can say
so if I face opposition I tell them how
much you know about me tell me your
story tell me about your upbringing why
did you come to the conclusion of the
opinions that you have today tell me I
remember when this happened that okay
great can I tell you why I came to this
conclusion yes here's mine is it fair
that we have different reasons why do we
came to this conclusion you got
life-changing experience like that as
well how about we respect each other let
me make my case to you you make your
case to me let's see if anybody can
persuade the other person your game with
that let's have a civil conversation so
that's typically what happens when I
face somebody that fully disagrees uh
with some of my views